hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're gonna be
going over a really cool game from round
2 of the 2013 candidates tournament why
it's gonna be played by Levon Aronian
and blacks gonna be played by Boris
Gelfand now those not too familiar Boris
actually won this tournament last year
so he has a ton of experience actually
going deep in these tournaments and
winning them so keep that in mind as we
play but this up until you know this
point is has been the most exciting
match so I'm really excited to do some
commentary and go over it
both extremely talented players but
we'll go ahead and just jump into it
white starts with Knight to f3 and then
pawn c5 and then pawn here to seaboard
this is kind of the English opening this
is the symmetrical English opening with
both sides kind of opting for you know
this pawn to c4 and pawn to c5 there
black responds with just Knight to c6
you know pretty common White's gonna
play Knight to c3 again kind of that
symmetrical English as we talked about
and then pawn to G's g6 you know has the
ability to bring his bishop here to g7
try to control these dark squares in the
board white also has the same you know
opportunity he can play you know pawn
here to g3 and try to control the center
with his bishop here kind of that modern
opening as far as controlling the center
with your minor pieces and sets plays
pawn here to to e3 recognizing you know
he can play now his pawn to d4 also
opening up for his bishop to protect
this pawn here on c4 so kind of some
flexibility hasn't really said one way
or the other if he's going to you know
bring his bishop here to g2 being kiddo
on the kingside and castle so it's still
leaving himself a lot of different
options as far as what liván wants to do
here so horse decides to play Knight to
f6 again getting his minor pieces
involved usually you are gonna want to
develop your nights before bishops
that's kind of a saying nights before
bishops so that's kind of what we have
here especially in this English opening
is the Knights getting involved into the
board then you have pawn here to d4 kind
of striking the stern of the board
saying hey I want to control
specifically with my pawns and then
after the pawn takes and lavond
recaptures then Bors comes down and
plays pawn to d5 really doesn't want to
have to deal with you know pawn here to
d5 chasing the night away this is kind
of a pain
so really just this pawn to d5 is more
of a hey I really just don't want to
have to deal with this pawn moving
forward unless about you know trying to
counter-attack the center of the board
but lavon's just gonna go ahead and take
with this pawn and after the knight
comes then the Queen's gonna come here
to b3 and I was kind of excited to see
this move because it is fairly
aggressive move from Livan this is you
know he had a lot of different options
as far as you know if he could have got
this Bishop out you know early on but he
got his Queen out right away in b3 and
so this is not only attacking this pawn
here on b7 it's also attacking this
quote this night here on d5 and
indirectly it's attacking the pawn here
on f7 which is pretty exciting as far as
you know this English opening you don't
see this all that often so after the
Knight takes here White has a few
options he can always take with his pawn
right here he can always take with his
queen probably wouldn't be as advised
because it's no longer as active as it
used to be so you know if you if he had
the choice he would just going to take
with this pawn but play the nice little
in-between move and played this Bishop
here to c4 basically saying hey you know
blacks gathered to thin this square on
s7 which early on is a weakness for
black because the only you know piece
that's really defending it is the king
and so right now is it's kind of you
know getting a bishop involved into the
game the center of the board really
controlling the center with his
LightSquared bishop and since he has
this Queen behind he knows okay next
move I can take with my pawn if I want
to but now I have this bishop that's
kind of buying me an extra move and I'm
really winning that development
standpoint so from here black decides
you know he could've played something
like pawn to e6 if you wanted to instead
he plays Knight here to d5 which makes
sense wants to go ahead and you know
bring his knight back and he is okay
with this position right here so he you
know black definitely had options this
is kind of what he chose from here the
pawn is gonna come to e6 kind of forcing
that Bishop to go somewhere
the bishop decides to just go ahead and
recapture so after recapture this is
kind of you know where we're at and this
is what I want to talk about a little
bit as far as what both sides are
looking to do so if we look at it first
from blacks perspective one of the
things he's looking
okay he doesn't have any of his pieces
developed so he's definitely behind in
the development game he definitely needs
to make sure that his King is safe so
he's probably gonna be looking to get
his dark squared Bishop involved into
the game castle on the kingside
obviously his Queens has you know
completely messed up as far as you know
any structural to you know keep his King
safe he also wants to get his light
square Bishop um to the game usually
these sevens kind of more of a passive
move it's really not doing anything so
look for a move like b7 or b6 or ACE
excuse me you know somewhat of an
aggressive move to get that involved
definitely wants to get both of his
rooks involved right now they're not
doing anything so McGinnis how many
pieces you have a how active they are so
also wants to get his queen involvement
of the game you can always play move
like Queen to d5 this nice little
outpost for any of his pieces because
White doesn't have a LightSquared Bishop
it's gonna be a little harder for him to
kind of put pressure on you know any you
know piece right here so the Queen can
obviously come down right away put
pressure on here even if the Queen
exchanges here on d5 you know he does
have protection here so that's gonna be
completely fun also we have some semi
open files so there's a semi open file
here on the e-file on the C files to
look for rooks to come there they're
obviously gonna be a lot better on open
files or semi open files just because
they have a lot more room to go around
so kind of as we move forward in the
game we've kind of gone past the the
opening for the the English there's a
lot of different variations but this is
this is one of the main book lines and
now we get into the middle game so it's
always kind of good to think about okay
what are both sides really trying to do
and what are they trying to accomplish
because you always want to have a plan
going into the middle game white now
plays castling on the King side again
want to get that king side safety and
black plays Bishop here to e7 now he had
the choice he could have you know played
bishop here to g7 I don't necessarily
know that that would have been a
horrible move but again he wants to make
sure that he can cast on the King side
White's gonna play Bishop to e3 and this
is completed development for white so he
has now connected his rooks so he can
now start to get those developed into
the game all of his pieces are developed
he's definitely winning the development
game compared to black so black has some
some moves he definitely used to make he
goes in and plays Queen to the
getting his Queen palm to the game next
you know he'll definitely wanna get his
LightSquared Bishop Castle usually on
the kingside and start to try to have
some sort of counter-attack or kind of
hold on you know depending if he wants
to play for a draw
he can always play you know somewhat
defensive now the roofs gonna come over
to see one kind of controlling this you
know semi-open file then black decides
to go ahead and take here on b3 which
makes sense you know after the pawn
takes here on b3 White has doubled pawns
but if we kind of look at it black has
some weaknesses as well again here on
the B file double pawns are definitely
weakness but black has an isolated pawn
here on c6 and he also has a backwards
pawn here on a seven so black has you
know a few things that Y can really Zone
in on and start to attack white also is
controlling for both the backwards pawn
in the isolated pawn he has rooks all
knows to me open files so he's going to
be able to apply a ton of pressure he
can also you know play knight here to e5
putting pressure on this pawn on c6 so
both sides have weakness but both sides
really know exactly what they need to do
to put pressure on the other side black
responds with Bishop here to b7 again he
needs to make sure that he develops all
his pieces and he also wants to protect
this pawn here on c6 after the the route
came over to see one attacking this this
pawn has to have a defender there or is
just gonna lose it now white plays
Knight to e5 again trying to overload
this pawn here on c6 right now there's
two attackers and there's only one
defenders and then black plays King
Castle now this game when I was watching
I I assumed LaVon was going to snap take
you know this pawn on c6 and then
high-five one of his neighbors but
instead he did it and it took me a few
moves to figure out what he was gonna do
because again this this pawn is just
kind of hanging out there you know even
if he takes and the bishop recaptures
you know the rook is going to take here
on c6 now obviously black can come over
he can swing bring his rook over to b8
put pressure on this pawn on b3 I'll
definitely have to play somewhat
defensive if you
wants to kind of hold on to this but
still he's up in material I thought for
sure he would do this instead in the
actual game he played rook over here to
a four and so kind of looked like one of
those things where he was gonna play
rook over to you know c4 potentially and
put more pressure on there if he just
wanted more pressure but it was kind of
a I don't really understand why he's not
playing this because everyone kind of
looked at it and said okay this is this
is good this is not a bad move for white
at all why not just capture this piece
or the pawn there on c6 but black went
ahead and responded with rook over to
the 8th starting to put pressure on his
own
you know square on d4 kind of a
counter-attack if you will and then
white played Knight over here to c4
again I still thought LaVon was going to
play Knight takes here on c6 but he
decided not to and because this Knight
took a gaffe on kind of saw an
opportunity and played bishop you to f6
now he's putting extra pressure on this
pawn on d4 he is now overloaded he now
has a rook here on d8 and a bishop here
on f6 and it was kind of okay is he now
putting more pressure on LaVon it what's
LaVon gonna do another Vaughn played a
nice little move and he played Knight
here to a5 and then it kind of all
started to make sense as far as what he
wanted to do he didn't want to go ahead
and take here on c6 and said he wanted
to rearrange his knight over here on a5
and put a lot of pressure on there so
now he's not only pressuring you know
the bishop here on b7 but now he's also
putting pressure on you know the pawn on
c6 so again all the pressure before and
he's also now you know double protected
with his rook here on a4 and the bishop
here on a3 so if you kind of look at
this it now makes sense he's actually in
a better position than he was he's still
putting the same pressure you know then
before it's not gonna make sense now you
know the the rook can come over because
he still has to you know worry about
this Bishop here on d7 black responds
with rook to d7 again he wants to
protect this Bishop on me 7 and this
Bishop doesn't want to move right away
because it's protecting you know the
pawn here on c6 and white responded with
a really good move in any played rook to
be four again trying to overload all of
his pieces trying to put
black in a really tough spot now he
wants to be careful because I was
looking I was like well okay you know he
could always try for you know night here
to see six again this this looks
somewhat overloaded but then you know as
I looked more about it and some other
people were doing some commentary I saw
the move rook here to c8 and this is a
really tough move for you know LaVon to
really deal with because you know you
could see you know the rooks swing over
to c4 now and then after let's say the
rook takes and then the rookie recapture
and then we could have you know the
bishop takes and then the rook takes and
then we could have the bishop coming
down here to to d4 and this is gonna be
somewhat of a problem because now black
is even in material but he doesn't have
doubled pawns right here so White's kind
of taken the initiative and the
advantage that he has and kind of thrown
it away because white really has to
recapture now because you know he
doesn't want to lose this pawn right
here and he doesn't want to play you
know super passive with move like Bishop
here to c1 so this is definitely gonna
be good for black so in the game you
know obviously he didn't take and
instead he just moved his rook over here
to b4 which like again was was
definitely better here come back here
the Brooke came over here to be four so
this is definitely a better move for
white and then black played Bishop here
to a6 again wants to make sure that you
know this over lated this overloaded
bishop here on b7 is protected and then
white now took on c6 so again I thought
he was gonna take many many moves before
and I don't still think it was gonna be
a terrible move if he did but this is a
much much better position for white and
he's just in a much more dominant
position again this rook is much more
active than it was here let's say on a1
it was kind of pretty you know this semi
open file but now it's completely
dominating right here why it's also
threatening Knight here to b8 which is a
really horrible move that black would
have to deal with it it just has so many
threats right here and it's also
protected by the this rook and this rook
on the H is not doing a whole heck of
lot he really needs you know Boris
really needs to get this piece
involvement to the game but this night
is just causing so much havoc for black
this is a really really good position
for white black that responds with the
rook over to b7 again he has to kind of
stop this this Knight coming here to b8
and then white plays pawn to h3 kind of
allowing himself some some breathing
room if he ever needs to move his King
away and then the King's also gonna come
here to g7 making sure that their Kings
you know can't be attacked later on by
rooks they just don't want to have to
deal with it at all
and so Knight now takes on or excuse me
the roof now takes on b7 and then after
the bishop recaptures then the knight
swings over here to e4 and this does two
things one that kind of blocks off this
bishop from attacking the pawn here on
d4 but that also kind of opens up the
door for you know this rook to get
involved into the game so you know the
rook on the second rank or the seventh
rank are very very strong so you know
White's looking to bring his rook here
to to c7 and really reign havoc
obviously he would want to swing it over
to f7 if he could because it's protected
by the knight but also putting pressure
on the bishop on b7 black really has to
respond to that so he plays Bishop here
to d8 a good thing about this is if
you're forcing your opponents to defend
with their major and minor pieces that's
awesome because this Bishop here on d8
is not active at all it's not
controlling the center of the board all
it's doing is controlling this c7 square
and it's also blocking off the rook here
on a8 which is not really what black
wants to be doing right now white now
responds with pawn to b4 again starting
to push those pawns forward and put more
pressure on black and then rook comes
over to ca now in the game this was kind
of the deciding factor because what
Boris Gelfand didn't recognize is that
across from him was going to be just a
complete animal that had one of the best
moves we've seen in the internment so
far definitely in this game it was kind
of the turning point and it makes sense
you know
trying to alleviate some of this
pressure here he doesn't want to have to
deal with this rook coming here to c7
kind of blocking off this bishop from
doing anything so yeah makes sense you
know if you know if the trade here on
see a thin the bishop
come here to see eight and then it's
kind of an okay to bishop pair verse a
knight and a bishop this is gonna be
completely fun unfortunately for black
he did not see the move Bishop here to
h6 and this is just a devastating move
you know if the King does take here on
h6 then the rook can now come and then
if the bishop takes then the knight can
come here to f7 and fork this this
Bishop here on D a so you know if King
two to g7 then the knight takes here on
d8 and this is just gonna be very very
bad for black not only Z down to
material but you know white can just
immediately put all of his pawns on dark
squares this light square Bishop no
longer means anything
and then this knight can just go around
gobbling up pawns and you know white can
centralized and have a very easy game
from there so great move that he
actually saw this now in the game black
decided not to go down this path instead
he played you know King here to g8 which
makes sense he doesn't want to you know
capture and then just being a complete
world of hurt
but unfortunately for him his King just
really can't move a lot now it's kind of
blocked off with this Bishop here in h6
and so you know while white can
definitely get his King
centralized and put a lot of pressure on
black black really can't do much with
his King so if we kind of go back just a
minute and say okay well rook to c8 was
definitely not the best move so what
what could have black done it as far as
trying to equalize it and he did have
you know a decent movement and so he
could have played Bishop here to d5 and
so always looking for these nice
outposts for your minor pieces you know
the night here on e5 is nicely placed
because it's defended by this pawn here
on d4 you know black had the same thing
he was worried about his bishop being
attacked on b7 so he could've easily
brought his bishop here to d5 and had a
nice little outpost it's again white
still has a small advantage but it's not
real clear how he's gonna take advantage
of that especially now with black kind
of controlling this into the board but
we get into the game you know the route
came over here to see eight and then
after the bishop then the King comes
back to GA now white now decided to go
ahead and recapture or capture here on
c8 and then after the bishop took then
the Knights gonna come over here to c6
again just putting so much pressure
on black heat he's now threatening both
this bishop here on d8 he's also
threatening the pawn here on C on a 7
Black has to be careful he can't play
move like Bishop here to b6 which
someone makes sense you know he's now
protecting both of them because now the
knight can just come over here to e7 and
4 could be bishop here on CA so can't do
that instead decides to go ahead and
play a bishop here to f6 saying okay if
you're gonna take my pawn on a7 that
that's not the worst thing ever I'm
gonna recapture here on d4 and put
pressure on you so again definitely you
know one of the better moves and so pawn
just now starts to push forward to b5
again anytime you kind of have this this
lead in space right here you want to
kind of push it down your opponent's
throat and so pawn to b5 pushing those
pawns and now Bishop here to d7 again
attacking the knight here trying to have
some sort of pressure back here on ca
that's not doing a whole heck of a lot
and now the pawns coming forward to g4
now black has a few options in the game
he played pawn here to g5 which again
makes some sense kind of blocking off
with this Bishop can really do you know
we also could have tried something like
pawn here to a6 which makes sense you
know now the pawn can push forward but
then after the pawn takes you know we're
kind of look at me and say okay what's
gonna happen this this Knight no longer
has a protector this Bishop no longer
has a protector why it's definitely
still up its but again there's really no
great move for black now you know he
played this pawn to g5 which you know
it's it's okay it's not great white
responds with pawn to h4 saying okay I
don't mind you can go ahead and take
that because I'm just gonna push forward
and block off the only defender that you
had from this pawn and again I'm just
protecting it with my bishop so you
can't really take it with yours and so
after you know the bishop takes here on
c5 and the pawn recaptures then white
now has a passed pawn which is really
gonna be difficult for black to deal
with considering now white can get his
King involved into the game so after the
bishop comes back here to d8
you know now the King starts to get
involved into the game black really he
can't do much with his bishop like he
wants to because he has to worry about
this pawn coming forward and so the
bishop comes here to c7 unfortunately
for him he kind of has to stay there and
so after the King comes to h3 black was
forced to resign there was just no way
to stop the force he can't get his king
balm to the game as we talked about and
this King is just gonna be able to go
around the board and gobble up pieces
and come over here and start to attack
this bishop and there's no way for black
to really hold on so definitely an
exciting game for round two after round
one I was kind of curious after all the
matches tied if we were gonna just have
what I would consider boring chess where
players really try to go for a draw but
LaVon came out and from the very
beginning you could tell that he was
going for a win here you want to make
sure that he was gonna take the lead
after day two so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video definitely more
exciting on day 2 hear from one of the
top rated players in the world
definitely make sure that you check out
the website we're gonna have more
commentary from some of the other
matches but hopefully y'all enjoy and
I'll see y'all in the next video thanks
for watching